-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are talking to
Senator Amy Klobuchar.
It did seem as though one of the
things we lost to some degre
in the rush to fill this vacancy
was sort of lacked the tim
to properly reflect back o
Ruth Bader Ginsburg's life
I assume, as a fellow lawyer
she meant a great deal to yo
as a trail blazer in this field.
-She did.
I mean, she was someone that
never gave up, you know.
She was told women
shouldn't go to law school
She graduates one in her class
She is told that
she shouldn't argue cases
in front of a Supreme Cour
because a man
could get better decisions
and she won five out of six.
She ends up on the court
as an icon into her 80s
with her own hashtag,
Notorious RBG.
And I was reminded of this
My daughter actually
went with me to a party,
and Justice Ginsburg was there
And we took a picture of the
three of us and she came to me
My daughter was like --
her first year in college.
Comes to me afterward, she goes,
"Mom, I got to put this
on my Facebook.
Notorious RBG is so cool.
But I hope you don't mind.
I cut you out, Mom."
[ Laughter ]
"I cut you out of the phot
'cause she's just so cool.
But to think --
-Here is the photo right there
-Oh, there it is.
-And this is how it looked
on social media.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, that's about it.
-That's exactly right,
and they have matching glasses
But I think the other thin
about the Justice is,
which I said at the hearin
because I think people
who are dispirited by what the
Republicans are doing right no
have to remember that
when Justice Ginsburg
wrote her dissents,
and the rabbi said this
at her memorial service
in the Capitol,
they weren't cries of defeat
They were blueprints
for the future,
and that's what this election is
and that's what she stood for.
-I want to talk about
election night,
and you and some of your
colleagues put out a report,
basically preparing people for
how and what might happen
on election night that we migh
not have a result early on
that we, obviously,
have a president
who is already
trying to sow
a level of distrust
in the results.
If you could just sort of
summarize for us,
what do you think is
the best course of action
for people watching
the returns coming in?
-Mm-hmm. Well, the first thing
I'm going to be in Minnesota
and so he has specifically sai
in my state
he's never coming back there
if he loses, so I'm just waiting
for that moment because we'r
winning in Minnesota.
And then the second thing,
that night is people have to
understand that we're not goin
to know the results
in some states, maybe includin
in some of the Senate races.
Every state's different.
It's not just
when their ballots are due
It's also how they count them.
So, you'll have
states like Florida,
which actually will
count them early,
and we may know right away
But then you'll have --
unless it's really close -
then you'll have states like
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
that are starting to count
the day the ballots come in,
and so you're going to hav
differences in each state.
And I think our message --
and Bernie's worked on thi
with me a lot --
our message is it's okay
that we don't know every state
We want to make sure that
every single vote is counted
and we don't want
Donald Trump to be
making some claim just because
a bunch of mail-in ballots
haven't been counted yet because
that's the way the law works
that there is something wron
with that.
So we just want people
to be ready for that.
-Do you have a personal plan
for how you are going to watch
and consume media
on election night?
-Probably I'll be in my home
state, as I said, at my house,
you know,
with my own little signs,
whatever,
just like everyone else.
We may have a small gatherin
in Minnesota,
but I think a lot of this for me
is holding Donald Trump
to his words.
He said he's never coming back
again, so I'm going to have to
get some swag for him or som
kind of going-away gift.
-Yeah.
-And I think that
the whole thing for people
to remember is
we can think of that night, bu
if you're just making that pla
and you don't have a plan to
vote, a big mistake
because I was on a call with
a bunch of kids and I said
"How many of you voted?"
and like 10 of them
raised their hand.
I go, "Okay, get off
the Zoom call right now."
Like, just vote.
That's what people have to do.
-You mentioned COVID and how i
affected your family personally,
and the fact that there is not
right now any reason to believ
there's going to be any more
relief before the election
Do you feel as though
your colleagues across the aisle
in the Senate have ignored
how this is affecting
the American people right now?
-Yes. I think it's part of
their denial.
The leader of their party,
you know, got COVID,
and walked into the White Hous
and defiantly took off his mas
while he was still contagious,
and to me that photo
says it all.
And then they have had
a bill on their desk --
it's called the Heroes Act
and different versions of it
that Speaker Pelosi
has passed --
that has the adequate mone
for testing,
that has the help for
state and local, and mostly,
this last version that passe
the House, restaurants,
Stages -- that's a bill
that I lead.
It's a bipartisan bill
that actually helps
some of our smaller theaters
and music stages,
so important in every town i
America, not just New York City,
small towns and mid-sized town
like Moorhead, Minnesota.
And so they have literally
let all of those bills sit
and all they've offered us
is just basically things
that wouldn't really get our
economy to where it should be.
So I have no idea why
they have chosen to disregar
the needs of America while mom
are balancing their kids
on their knees and their lapto
on their desk,
and seniors are isolated.
It's unbelievable to me, but I
guess we'll have to wait and see
what the suburban women
say because,
Seth, I was watching that
earlier on your show.
I grew up in the suburbs, okay
I know what a lot of suburba
women think right now.
-Yes.
-This is just not right.
It's not normal,
and they want a president which,
as you point out, they can wak
up every morning and not worry
that they have to turn off
the TV because they don't want
their kids to watch
what the president's saying.
-Well, it's certainly
going to be
an interesting couple of weeks
or so.
Thank you so much
for making the time for us
and we will talk to you soon
-Okay. It was great to be on
Thank you.